survivors of the deadly school shooting
in Florida say they're turning their
anger to action as investigators reveal
they failed to act on warning signs
thousands of people gathered in Fort
Lauderdale over the weekend demanding
tighter gun control laws other groups
are planning a series of protests across
the country next during the next several
weeks after that weekend rally a hundred
students plan to visit Florida's
legislature tomorrow to call for a ban
on assault weapons Adriana Diaz spoke to
four survivors of the shooting at
Marjory Stoneman Douglas high school
she's in parkland Florida this morning
Adriana good morning good morning the
students told us they are fighting for
change for the 17 victims memorialized
here that's why they're getting on buses
tomorrow to go to the State Capitol with
petitions in hand most of them were born
after Columbine in 1999 so they've never
known a world without school shootings
but they want theirs to be the last
never again that's the rallying cry from
student survivors fueled by the loss of
their peers
Emma Gonzales is one of the teens
calling up politicians to pass stricter
gun laws along with Delaney Tarr David
hog and Cameron Caskey what do you think
is the one thing about your generation
that you that can really spark change
here the fact that we're getting shot
and I hate that it took hitting me right
at home for me to get involved with this
but I just have to forgive myself for
that and keep moving the thing is as
much as I would love to be worrying
about prom dresses and college
acceptance letters in my mind I can't
think about anything now except change
all I can think about is those 17 faces
they're taking their movement nationwide
with the march on Washington next month
how does a March friend change I think
of all the things that have happened
since the first woman's March we've had
the media movement and along with those
women it's it's our turn and it's the
grieving students turn to put an end to
this in the earth we're going to make
ourselves so loud so brazen that they
won't be able to ignore us in the White
House this is all about gaining a
platform so that we can discuss with
them creating common sense gun laws and
stricter gun legislation we want assault
rifles off the market automatic
semi-automatic have no place in civilian
society is it a slippery slope do we
start with ar-15s and then more gun
rights or taken away from people
that's the thing that we have a right to
live at this point what does it mean to
have rights to have guns what we're on
right now is a slippery slope that we're
getting to the bottom of this needs to
be where we stop and we start to stand
up and they expect millions to stand
with them when they march we asked how
they could affect real change if many of
them aren't even old enough to go to the
polls they said we can't vote but we can
be heard and they've got their eyes on
the midterm election Nora
and then they are being heard Adriana
thank you so much